Ron Bennington Earl Douglas from the
Bennington show it's the return of Earl
Douglas Ranjan dairy producer I can't
tell you like Travis and I have talked
about it multiple times cuz obviously
Travis and I are the only ones left in
the office that have been around since
57th Street yeah and when we started
seeing Earl Douglas Febreeze himself
yeah in that office like on a daily
basis it just makes us smile every day
you know a Jimmy I guess you go back I
go back with it were there else instead
ewf oh yeah like what 18 years ago um
yeah mm about 2000 yeah that's crazy
yeah how few people are still doing you
know this kind of radio yes those days
how did you end up getting Earl Douglas
back in the fold did you have to
convince him did you have to convince
serious have you tried before and they
said no because the last time we said
and the reason I called him Febreze the
last time we saw him he was so stressed
out he invented an allergy to Febreze
that would make him pass out that wasn't
made up there was too much Febreze in
that studio I'm the first to admit it
but Ron or frezzer whoever would spray
Febreze in a room and it would make our
old lose consciousness yeah and it
really wasn't too long after that that
Earl left radiating a break well he yeah
he took a sweet break for himself and
left kind of crazy right Earl I mean you
had a an exit thing here that was insane
yeah it's legendary nhr what happened
was your exit he gave a speech where he
thought he and the company should be
heading and yeah and I got on the errand
no no no no it was off the air and when
he left you know they were you know how
they get concerned around here Jerry
leaves and what they're gonna do of
course and the word postal with his ID
removed immediately yeah yeah that's the
whole thing here is like don't come back
in
it's a big part right Earl didn't lose
those things you you were able to stop
back everyone so well yeah I was I did
your show a couple of times afterwards
and it was cool it was cool
do you remember what Earl's idea was for
a better satellite radio it was going to
be was gonna be in-depth rock and
in-depth Rock yeah Rock he was gonna
take the rock hard he might mean him to
go in a direction that he still talks
about with me to this day right heavy
yeah but of course it wasn't the show
that they bought you know I mean so he
took some time still but you know Earl
goes back before all of us in New York
radio yes
wait you was Scots oh right yeah I
started in w1 aw in 1989 wow that was
really doing the public file or it was
this before that or after that yeah I
became was it public service director
and then the I won't say 90 follow you
and he was also our union rep no I was
never to you I became the de facto union
rep I was never the union representing
became the de facto also safety safety
manager be the safety manager yeah yeah
one job it was like the deputy fire
something how does the guy handle all
those responsibilities to be you know in
charge of public service and the union
and everybody's safety yeah well that's
a lot members I think that was all after
9/11 - sir Oh Mike when it really got
really crazy about this great story
about the fire alarms going off and
everything at at the old ne W and he
looks out the window and saw just these
URLs face the safety manager looking
straight up we gotta go
just kiss stands in the way so you stay
in the ability to make sure everyone was
out safely yeah and I was like let's go
every because you got a the drill was
yeah you gotta run the drill so you just
said that the why you left him up there
to burn use the one in the burning
building yeah the baby didn't want to
jump window so we put him in a fireman's
carry and why not that's why they call
it that
what did you do all these years you were
away from radio you left see what you
did you leave serious Oh 2009 what he
been doing for the last nine years most
of it was at the have been at the hot
rod and what was your job there
I play records you play records late
bags oh so you play records but I mean
what's the job title um vibe manager
[Laughter]
manager [ __ ] job what do you will
you in charge the vibe yeah basically
you set the tone of the building so if
let's say this guitar is on the wall
what do you think let's say he's in town
and we have a room full of Osby why play
hard rock/metal you know one of you I
suppose just playing like what else
might you play like did they like no we
don't want to hear any bad company we
don't wanna hear any soft rock no
stealing Dan but you try to fill that
out you try to for the vol I think I
think James question is like what would
stop them from just having an intern put
on the best of Black Sabbath you're a
Pandora Channel right well I know it
well my expertise and now what would you
do if a black family walked in how would
things have changed yeah that's cool but
that seems like it's stereotyping
doesn't it it does but they probably
offended and then they'd look up at the
vibe manager and realize these early
I go yeah I guess that's fine then the
vibe has changed that's what people do
though and they feel the vibe changing
they immediately start looking where's
the vibe manager in here who's doing
what have you saw Sam walking in what
would the vibe
he suddenly would change the vibe of the
room what would you play um Sam's on my
wedding I would assume mm-hmm
probably like Foo Fighters yeah are you
still there yeah
oh you are still there yeah I'm working
tonight oh okay sweet that's enough to
pay your rent that like meaning like
that's a full-time job it's not open in
the morning it's it's afternoon but it's
just a really like when somebody tells
you this is my job and you go that's
they pay you full time for that I get so
many hours that it didn't seem like the
hours you work wouldn't be enough to
cover evening I mean they're from
basically five until clothes Oh hose at
one o'clock on during the week and 2:00
a.m. okay you have an iPad right that's
yeah I pad it's a video database we've
also have some audio in there
where's your office or where's your
where do you vibe from how do you figure
out the vibe of a room from the office
Earl's got to be on the floor UT are you
in a DJ booth no where do you play from
we have an iPad so you just walk around
the room with your iPad yeah I mean but
I'm I'm helping everybody out I mean the
restaurant business is really crazy I
mean you could do your doing everything
you could be scouting tables you could
be bussing tables you could be moving
table a lot with tables so yeah you're a
busboy where the [ __ ] iPad instructed
by the way I do think there there would
also if the hardrock hired a vibe
manager and made him also act as a
busboy that feels racial meaning to
position right like I don't know if they
would do that to a white 5 manager is
what I'm saying
I don't know I'm you know it feels
prejudice no it feels like that the job
of vibe manager is being disrespected
the job itself is that right they're
saying hey we don't think this is a very
important job so you can do this while
you're doing that and why aren't you
like a hype manager instead you should
be like the hype guy like have a
microphone and an iPad yeah I see never
thought of that answered myself a hype
guy no not at all you're more a vibe guy
yeah you could something like music
stuff yes this room right now what would
you put on for us what would you you
like you look around like oh the guys
are all together again that's tough cuz
you got hard rock jam you got millennial
Sam wears their own yeah you know Ronnie
you like Elvis Costello right right
Morrison is love and understanding great
but any Troy's in here to enjoy salt add
it up what do you do you walk into this
room you see it like skate punk what do
you do at this point yeah like yellow
card what do you what do you play for
all of us well you get the iPad on what
do you put a tap for Ron I would start
with this no it's for a room leading
together four of us are eating together
that's right yeah and then of course
Anthony's in there and you know you got
to have a den tonight that I know he
[ __ ] loves that stuff he does
something with an organ and a monkey to
get him going all right start with
Soundgarden yeah that's a place we all
meet yeah you know Soundgarden maybe
sits for me you know I mean like I don't
want to get too deep right system of it
down then move into you know Jay geils
popular give me your centerfold I like
that one so how do you make the transit
I mean not that you made the transition
because you're still a vibe manager but
how do you come to this realization I've
mastered the art of vibe managing I want
to get back into this radio thing I mean
I got a thing mr. Ronnie be right here
you really don't have to
he really made it happen how did it
happen phone call and Nina Chan's
meeting it was a text actually right
send me a text I think was a memorial
right before Memorial Day weekend yeah
and then how long did it take us to get
you it
um two months yeah well I thank you guys
convincing serious that he's not gonna
do another one of these speeches yeah
the thing is I was on the road one day
and I get a call from Earl and he goes
well thanks anyway buddy just the fact
and they had called him and told him
that we're going in another direction
and I go Earl there isn't another
direction you were the only person yeah
emails basically saying it and that was
like okay that was that that was how you
get fired
no that was this time we're trying to
fire back in pastoral
so with no other options he they were
like we're gonna go with nothing right
now
right I see and then I called wiki and I
go come on dude what the [ __ ] and he
goes he didn't have anything to do it
was HR because once they put these tags
on you right here I mean that's the
problem that's why we can't get Eastside
Dave back in the [ __ ] building yeah
just to say hi because he made a couple
of [ __ ] murderous threats and that
doesn't leave and he's like to me he's
like the well the guy left and I go yeah
but that [ __ ] thing you know it's
just stuck to you somehow yeah yeah I
mean everyone makes him a murderous
threat occasionally yeah good man's
fault Earl didn't make it murderous
through no but they was still they were
like you left the company we don't want
yeah we don't know exactly in that file
but it's something did you ask her let
me show you your file no does that
concern you do you go to HR and go like
hey guys now that I'm here and we're all
one happy family just what was the
hiccup no it doesn't bother me at all
right I'm like moving for how do you
smooth doubt how do they get smooth
doubt it turned out that it was an it
was an older because I think I tried a
couple years ago it was an older one and
they had rejected that woman they never
got a rap but they called them two years
after no no you know you can't really
interact with HR it's crazy I mean the
biggest bosses that we have they can't
go to HR it's a totally separate thing
we can't go to it they it's like you
couldn't like the president company can
go and say hey can we take care of this
thing that's away from them this is like
between them and the lawyers that's how
come
HR was set up and all the years that I
worked in radio we never had a [ __ ]
HR right to Pyke JA now it's a huge
floor right where is it somewhere in
like thirty seven and I think some of
its up the street we didn't really know
those people yeah you know they don't
want it a lawsuits from the companies
right they're [ __ ] the company they
want HR to nip this [ __ ] in the bud
exactly it's exactly right it was a
setup so that people particularly the
creative people can't do their ideas
radio the people that we used to take on
like the youngest producer would do just
the guy [ __ ] hanging around the
balloon every time that there was
something and went out this [ __ ]
idiot or some caller who would call too
much amigo like dude you wanna do you
just want to [ __ ] be in radio kymaro
we're gonna take your pants down we're
gonna put stuff up your ass yeah I mean
I I remember even when we were on 57th
Street the intern hiring process has
changed dramatically
in ten years yeah you know it used to be
like this will be a fun guy for the air
right and now well interns are not for
the air interns we got to make sure
we're teaching them and and all about we
can't have them and responsibility
people always say to me how's Radio
change I go well we don't see the
interns tits anymore you know [ __ ]
major change guys and girls
yeah yeah yeah they used to build to do
anything and now you can't write any of
that stuff so have you met a charm sorry
Sam have you met them or no I'm not I
don't know one of them
I really don't either I don't know one
of them you know they send interns in
that they think would fit the show or
whatever but we're not even part of that
process anymore they are so like Scott
and Andrew those guys they really can't
tell HR to do any they can't tell them
to do a damn thing there I think their
strategy historically for us in terms of
finding interns their strategy has been
the ones that sway says no to right
doing our show yeah so they deal with
the attorneys yeah that's it yeah and I
mean yet you don't want to mean with
lawyers in a charge you know not
that is the worst [ __ ] thing there's
never a fun experience with lawyers in
the HR great yeah I mean it's it's 99%
of the time bad news when the lawyers
are familiar with you or your show know
anything that's happened you know I mean
well they're not putting a value on that
they're just looking at a piece of paper
and saying how does this play yeah how
does this play that's all they care
about how can we cut ourselves how can
we cut out this cancer before it gets
into the bones or metastasize right so
you brought Earl back and then you
shocked the world I was telling you
right before we started that Jim and I
couldn't be the Thanksgiving show this
year because we were in LA we were
zipped across the coast yeah which we
were bummed about and especially bummed
about when I started looking at the
pictures the day the Thanksgiving show
is getting recorded yeah and none other
than pistil Fez Watley
yes walks out on stage for the first
time since he left yeah and I mean I
listened back to it obviously and the
reaction that he got was unreal it was
crazy how do you guys sneak him in that
was very [ __ ] difficult because we
didn't even want we didn't want hard
rock Johnny or wiki or anybody to know
because you know how they are they're
like a little [ __ ] loose lips oh yeah
you know they go so we couldn't even
plan this bit but we did a real
old-school radio bit where you know it
was uh this is your life and big a the
insult comic came by keith was there
orient yeah Keith Robinson was there the
place went [ __ ] crazy for him till
and then stalker patty and I'm like what
this isn't even my [ __ ] life this is
ona his life why is this up here and
then then she was like all right we've
got a phone call that we're gonna put up
we're gonna FaceTime and I was like I
you know there's one thing I learned in
this last year's and I'm not a victim
anymore and I'm not going to I'm gonna
stand up to my abuser and I'm not going
to take any call from a man who [ __ ]
physically and spiritually and sexually
abused me Fez Watley so why I was doing
he came walking out as just [ __ ] old
WWWF [ __ ] right and was he on the
monitor or no no how he came walking out
from behind he's even a phone call cuz
people knew
yeah did even like a Skype call or a
phone call that would have been like a
big deal is your pitty of him walking
out I want to see that I've not seen
that I don't think there's video no no
now uh the [ __ ] hilarious thing about
it is we've been talking about this for
years
and we were saying like will do
something live but if we do if you're
like a regular caller or whatever who
gives a you know I mean it won't it
won't have the same pop so like in a
real [ __ ] old school you know
magician thing we [ __ ] waited as long
as we could but then in this time he had
another heart attack and now his heart
attacks are called silent heart attacks
because of his sugar diabetes have
[ __ ] numbed up his nerves he doesn't
feel the heart attack anymore Wow he
just fainted
woke up at the hospital and then two
days later they're like well we went
over you had a you know pretty bad heart
attack and they're having all the
[ __ ] swords Reza Henson don't forget
to stents he did a quadruple bypass Oh
God so this was after this is this he
had a heart attack after the bypass yes
oh my gosh what is it is it genetic with
him or what's going with this [ __ ] me
that's part of it and the other part and
this is true and I didn't I don't even
think I said this on my show but so gala
and I go over to run through this bit
with him right and he's very excited cuz
you know he hasn't done the stuff there
was [ __ ] six coke cans right he drank
six [ __ ] cokes that day and he's got
like going over your [ __ ] friend's
house after you got out of rehab and
seen a crack pipe it's the same [ __ ] so
what do you do at that point you going
Fuzzy's say a word what are you gonna do
at that point we had a job yeah that's
not the time or place
yeah because you want to believe at
first when he first started having heart
attacks you want to probably must be
just
stressed out he's on the air maybe he's
he the show is stressing him out and
then he goes home and he just keeps
having heart attacks he's worse than
ever
ya know he does a stress worse than ever
till I mean is he still stressed out
yeah
does he have any desire to come back up
and do some more radio you know the
thing was this wasn't the easiest thing
in the world for him either like this
was fairly exhausting he killed it he
hung around and science [ __ ] for people
I mean he was just [ __ ] great
but there might be you know some kind of
specialty programming or I don't know I
always talk to him if he wants to do a
podcast or something but right now he's
just you know dealing with his health
but he's still [ __ ] he's still a
great writer and he's just hilarious
I think he just got a bad hand yeah
maybe yeah no I saw him in Florida when
I was down there in Tampa he came was
really excited about that too yeah I was
happy to see him yeah I saw him at
WrestleMania when they were in Florida I
didn't even know he was gonna be there I
just thought we were at the Hall of Fame
and I'm just like who's that in the
front row I'm like that it's that fence
yeah but yeah I mean it was a I just
loved it the the reaction that he got
everybody went right along with the bit
that was going on and it was it was he
came out and he was my abuser and then
he slapped me in and Gail slapped me and
in Fez slapped me and then the you would
[ __ ] like this so then the whole
thing is like Chris tanley supposed to
come running out I stopped a punch and
then all of us put the boot store and
then we celebrate and then we bring
Chris up and we celebrate why we're
[ __ ] doing hogan's music it's just
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but Stanley as he
throws the punch and I block it he
[ __ ] dives on the ground no yeah he's
a [ __ ] idiot
I haven't even slightly let it go
[ __ ] tossing I'm like this bit was
going so [ __ ] great you ruin it in my
mind the audience has no idea but this
also [ __ ] Earl you missed the [ __ ]
thing too that you agreed to do Earl
would you miss what were you supposed to
do or oh because I noticed Earl wasn't I
was
that was his one eye so when I'm freaked
out that Fez is there Gail's trying to
get us together and I yelled I only yell
I've been triggered and then Earl was
gonna come running out and go hey
and I'm like triggered Earl trigger ha
ha ha but I look up and he's not [ __ ]
there he's not in his place where the
hell were you by managing were you vibe
managing we were to do a bit in your
home place like that I mean III had the
mic
you ain't nowhere near I need to be
where did Jack stay why didn't you come
out you don't have four back stages from
where you belong besides it's pretty
feet yeah you had a size maybe at the
top of the [ __ ] stairs why the line
it's quick you know I did you come out
and do it he's thinking about music is
that what happens sometimes you get at
the Hard Rock and even though the
bennington show is happening and that's
your new responsibilities you're home
now you start thinking about the vibe
and all of a sudden poor Ron is out a
producer because your mind is on the
vibe because he's thinking about its
American bent by Grand Funk not like the
joking you know what a participate in
that joke I'm only now getting woke I
don't know everything that's happening
in this world but you are getting there
kind of immune hit the snooze alarm but
I'm trying my best
I'm really really drowsy though is that
the issue that Ron's not woken up for
you is that why you just left him at the
dry Ron is very woken you have every
right to attack the white man after what
you put up with all why didn't you want
to do the bit I wanted to do the bit I
was mending I had the mic I had the
running grab a mic I was backstage I was
waiting for the line
how far is backstage it would have taken
you [ __ ] 18 [ __ ] seconds to get
there it was right at the wings what
goes on in your head oh my god is
driving me away you went away and then
why didn't I come out what happened you
didn't come out the top of the [ __ ]
stairs nobody would have been looking at
you cuz they're focusing on Fez you said
the line right no no I [ __ ] looked
over that he wasn't there you know what
I mean I had the [ __ ] punch out
uh-huh
thank you and then I got [ __ ]
Stanly landing in a dive walks [ __ ]
sweet you blocked his punch and he fell
and he fell [ __ ] so terrible and I
always wanted to just say you
[ __ ] yeah thank you to him after
constantly off the air - yeah yeah yeah
we had a he didn't [ __ ] answer some
texts when I was coming in yesterday and
I brought it up again I don't know why
did he answer you text yeah he said you
know he's busy doing all this stuff but
like falling down on the stage at the
wrong man when he doesn't have an answer
he goes [ __ ] silent run silent run
deep yeah you know what I bet he's the
one that taught [ __ ] Earl oh sure love
does the same thing what was that [ __ ]
right he goes silent constantly so he
gave you it basically a a terrible
soccer flop that was what he does he
threw you blocked at me [ __ ] soccer
flopped yeah
so when Earl's not on the side of the
stage are you thinking to yourself
he's been here for three weeks this is
fresh Earl this is new back on the scene
energy Earl you know already let me talk
to my mud pria woke Ron Barrington you
know I mean oh no no no we know what
happening yes that's not good Earl
that's on you by the way that's pre woke
Bennington comes back that's on did you
know you blew it yeah
when did you how did you know you blew
it I was clearly not on the stage did
you try to run well you see he said I'm
in backstage area he said trigger did
you run to the stage no he didn't say
did you think to yourself boy did I just
blow that or did you think oh oh I guess
we're on just decided not to do it I'm
in the clear I thought he wasn't just
not gonna do it but I should have been
in my spot but then you when did you
realize that that wasn't the case he was
making up for the fact that you blew it
you know no there was just so many
things going on that night but I should
have been in my spot
well you wouldn't you just you didn't
want to be in your spot no I just he
never got you've got heat of the moment
I just blew my spot did you forget or
you don't want to
they should be perfect right now yeah
talking to a girl Rosanna yeah what was
it it was it forgetfulness or did you
not want to do it yeah honey I was be
completely nice I was just so excited
that there's this yeah watch the show
instead of being in it yeah you realize
you hired a fan not a producer me I love
the blue spot did the dog's name with
you by bringing a roll back you know
what I mean by that fun yeah you get
some sweet you get some sour you got to
enjoy it all yeah Earl what was your
when when you were sitting there vibe
managing before you're back on
Bennington thinking about the run in fez
days what was your what were some of the
memories that you would think of that
you're like yeah I missed that well what
were they what were the great times oh
you were involved in obviously just
watching him do an interview that's
always really nice no I'm like seriously
hip watching it was like a clinic I
thought I watch you walk down memory
lane for hours yeah when I said what was
your favorite memory that you were
involved in you went for when Ron
interviewed he likes to watch you rock a
lot of people don't even know this but
Earl came back from a pretty bad
sickness too
it was touch-and-go when he was gone and
it was the last it was the last case of
sickle-cell you know before he had the
Febreze problem this is before you Sam
yeah he got a bed ulcer from working
with ona so much to this day he said he
almost died
all right to bleeding ulcers any of the
three blood transfusions I see you for a
week well your ulcers they're right here
dear he's pointing to his [ __ ] attack
it's not all so they're all why did you
why was why were you so stressed out
what was it that was stressing you after
that extent no I tried to make him ski
no time that I it turns out it's
actually
genetic betting just happened that one
time has it happen to you since you got
away from those guys I don't know but
I'm the Omni 8th kids is that why he's
all teens and club soda if you're all
sir that was part of it I'm the eighth
of I'm the yes I'm doing this to me and
why is it shocked no one that there's
eight kids in your family than I thought
and um
kids two four and six and eight all have
names by the way George George for let's
talk to the evens so way there's stuff
that you did you did a lot with Ron and
Fez I mean you were you were very a very
large part of that show he's well let me
tell you with the blood transfusion okay
right I came in and you had you were
tied up to two different blood
transfusion was going on and I was like
I was in the movie blade I'm like this
is so exciting
save see Wesley Snipes in the in his
biggest role with all the blood going
and everything yeah so what what was it
what was it that you were involved in
that you were like oh man that was a fun
time I missed that that was sure a bit
that my biggest bash was a highlight oh
yeah he boxed el Duques that oh that was
back when we were at any depth wise
right yeah it was fun who won I did do
you not like Al knockout but also called
Pheo yeah he totally called me up but
that was that was fun that was the best
shape I was in in my life is that we
trained for three months oh you really
did train yeah here's someone instruct
you in boxing yeah a real boxer yeah
there was a jimana JKD instructor and
yeah I got my ass kicked
it's really training but it's fun yeah
yeah we can't really put on the night of
fights anymore can we yeah i actually
that night this is how much radios
changed [ __ ] billy staples did
digs town challenge where he fought ten
listeners so we're like alright this
will you know how you do when you put
together a show you're like okay this
should take you know 28 minutes so that
you know yeah this is great we got this
whole segment right Gareth and about the
fourth or fifth guy [ __ ] just comes
out and hits him for the [ __ ] place
is going crazy um I got six more [ __ ]
guys wearing gloves and I just started
yelling at the wall like there was some
like what ladies and gentlemen this is
insane
they're telling me that he went the full
round and then the [ __ ] place is
booing and I'm like I'm yelling at no
one what are you [ __ ] you weren't
alright we've got to keep it going the
judges have their [ __ ] sounding so
it's trying to get staples up I'm moving
here you're supposed to work these
things like in the carny days you're not
supposed to actually have him fight
listener yeah well what are you gonna do
and you know in the carny days those
guys really were [ __ ] fighting yeah
that's where the chutes came from they
could actually win the fights yeah well
there's magic trying to get someone to
knock out a guy that works you know how
hard that would be to [ __ ] pull you
just can't what happens we said blind
the blind boxing yeah you just can't do
any that [ __ ] not all that's gone mm-hmm
all of it's all lawyers and some
lawsuits that that's people like why do
you do the same shot you can't they
won't let you do any of that [ __ ] yeah I
did
I had a [ __ ] kid in Florida and he
was his name was Billy the phone
freaking he was just this pale skinny
kid and I'm on the air and I said you
know the [ __ ] funny thing is is the
skinny and the weak as his [ __ ] is he
can beat any woman in a fight the
[ __ ] phones are blowing up women want
to fight him so we take him out the
first fight and he was like girl he
trained he beats the girl as we I put
him like through six or seven fights
over the next two years [ __ ] key
he's non-stop training he's getting
better and better so I'm doing this big
[ __ ] gig in the morning there's like
10,000 people in Tampa and we got Randy
Savage is the [ __ ] referee and his
[ __ ] billion he comes
he looks like a [ __ ] Navy boxer he's
just [ __ ] nailing this chick hits her
on the [ __ ] head she's out and not
waking up right she's not waking up and
I'm like [ __ ] man this is real you got
scared yeah I was scared because like
and [ __ ] savages next to me going I
don't know dude I don't think she's
coming back
I've seen this happen before I'm like
shut up man my whole [ __ ] career I've
got kids in private well you guys had
you you had sanctioned about and gotten
the proper insurance yeah
we didn't even have a [ __ ] medic
sitting by just a [ __ ] woman that our
[ __ ] producer knocked the [ __ ] out
isn't it crazy isn't it [ __ ] crazy
this when you look back at some of the
chances like how did that that was a
lawsuit or that was the end of the
career and that Randy Savage would just
be associated with it too
I don't know brother he would not give
me a [ __ ] positive vibe when did she
finally wake up it was like a minute or
so you know like I'm [ __ ] minute two
minutes and it was like that entire time
you can't breathe
you cannot [ __ ] breathe you're like
this we [ __ ] killed a woman's brain
damage yeah yeah I had Don Vito well and
this is before he did the BAM show he
dead no yeah and he was a guy that I
knew from my old neighborhood so this
was even before jackass he used to come
down and do [ __ ] on my show and we had a
[ __ ] chicken wing and beer eating
contest and on the way home we put him
with the sixth finger boy to go back to
his place he [ __ ] was laying back and
he threw up in his own throat and the
kid didn't [ __ ] tilt his head just
let him sit there with puke in it and he
[ __ ] went brained and I get I I come
home from my show you know what it's
like good mornings you're [ __ ]
exhausted in the afternoon I have to
tell you guys and I'm getting calls from
the hospital he said and I go there and
they said he's in a coma
and he's [ __ ] brain dead and I'm like
mother [ __ ] and I'm like I gotta call
his [ __ ] family and there was one guy
in his family I'm like I hope that
[ __ ] doesn't take a
because I remember he hit somebody in
the head with a brick when I was younger
I can figure out a way right you know
and I literally I was talking to his
parents about flying them down and
they're [ __ ] crying and then he just
[ __ ] sits up like the undertaker
starts [ __ ] pulling hoses out of
himself the doctors right we're gonna
run some more tests he's like [ __ ] you
I'm leaving here this is [ __ ]
ridiculous you had no brain activity he
goes because I was sleeping and now I'm
in this weird [ __ ] thing but
literally like I went from this guy's
dead I don't know how I'm gonna deal
with this
- please you got to get out of your
shoes I saw him put on his pukey shoes
that just go down the [ __ ] hall
trying to put on his clothes because I
didn't want to miss out on this Florida
vacation why didn't your guy turn him
over he's a [ __ ] idiot I mean the guy
has six fingers he's a [ __ ] circus
freak literally have [ __ ] baby
fingers coming out on the other side of
the baby finger you can't count on him
yeah yeah somebody on Twitter is
remembering when Earl had to be wheeled
out of the building after he faked
passing out after being sprayed by
liquid ass going so far to say that he
had memory loss about the entire
incident now I remember that I wrote to
the hospital with him because I wrote
with an audio recorder just to make sure
that we got everything because that
happened on ona I gotta write that
happened on ona and you guys were trying
to get updates because Ron defense was
on right after us at the time and so we
had to try to get Earl to the hospital
and try to snap him out of it so we
could get him back to 57th Street before
Ron and Fez was over so we could get the
update in and why did you have memory
loss no I got flipped on my head I got
knocked out by Hill Febreeze what's me
mom
Danny School Board me and I flipped over
and I went that's right Danny Boy he
Danny was crouched behind him Danny
Russel yeah I mean I got pushed it but I
don't I do
all you got pushed okay I got pushed and
I landed on my head the only thing I
remember was and when I was in the
hospital when they were like look at me
over yeah no actually I was in the
ambulance and I was like how did I get
here
did you pass out from the liquid ass no
no I'll tell you I got I got over and
over in and landed on the back of my
head he didn't break the whole time he
was in the hospital the whole time he
was in the hospital the ambulance it was
I don't remember I don't remember what
happened how did I it's not a [ __ ]
Squealer he is not a squid no or a liar
I believe him I still don't remember
what I totally believe her but do you
believe what he said about no showing on
Rana at the show yeah he [ __ ] up 1%
but he didn't even give an answer yes I
said I blew a spot the spot was a lot
happening who's come and joined the show
oh wait I forgot Jim's got a lifelong
defensive Earl I'm Timur Alcazar okay
Black Sabbath photo oh that's right
Ronnie Ronnie gave me his pastor [ __ ]
Earl never so here's what happened to
that this is really [ __ ] cuz it
[ __ ] went in to Jim's book that Earl
was a hero
so Earl's has passes to this and it's
Sabbath and and he you know I'm gonna go
with him and I go you know Jimmy's the
guy who [ __ ] loves Sabbath give him
my ticket and Earl went and took full
credit and said here's my did I not
credit you in a book my terrible apology
so no no you didn't know at the time
that was our idea
oh and then when I read the book I went
[ __ ] I could have been in this
book that I loved right
and instead you just got to read about
Earl Tori of your life right or all did
take a good picture and Earl didn't walk
backstage with me we just walked back to
hell like we belong there yeah it's
[ __ ] great that was the greatest now
you're late but it will never be
surpassed I'll tell you we talked about
when we were talking we were out in LA
and we were talking about the wildfires
I asked Jim what's the one thing you
would take out of your house if it was
burning down and and immediately it's
like my Sabbath photo because I signed
by all right hi Ralphie what am i a
decade I got it and that was like the
very beginning of you being able to have
those kind of experiences right but no
it was 2006 was it that late oh yeah
yeah yeah earlier I came home early I
left the comedy festival day early
because it was anticipated snowstorm so
I left the Aspen Comedy Festival
so you know that you're back in time
mm-hmm oh you must have been proud in
that moment knowing that mission
accomplished he was so happy because I
think you had lunch with I owe me this I
owe me that day me him and Steve Carly
see and Iommi's predict about putting a
possible Tony Iommi show I'm serious
or next time at the time and I knew that
it wasn't gonna happen probably we went
for lunch and had a great time and Steve
was good because he talked to Tony's guy
a lot so me and Tony just ate Cobb
salads and chatted away and you didn't
yeah you like that Tony made that
picture happened cuz Ozzy was walking
away he goes always come back and he got
lost you back for me I almost numbers
about how you totally took over the
press room turn the Cuban grass you were
you know you're you're supposed to sit
down he stands up and the kid the TV
cameras are in the back so he's
completely blocking the TV cameras this
screaming out he could care less
I have footage of that you can hear me
in the background but you could very
faint because it's not a tape properly
that was just shouting out fan questions
it all took black and white photos I put
one on Instagram recently photos by
Hieronymus but the thing was everyone he
asked the best questions of course it
says because I don't know one guy was
like what you guys want or they were
already on tour that happens all the
time yeah they did like those guys I'm
sitting his room full of so-called
journalists and they didn't know won't
work and he came in and just great
question there's a superfan it's like
this is my promise never never the
critics favorites okay we're not so they
always act like they're doing a [ __ ]
favor when they talk to those guys yeah
they really were shitty yeah and so yeah
I just kind of uh stood up and asked
questions you didn't mind that you were
taking the presses question I will never
forget how annoyed they were surrounding
great ass garbage yeah
every NASCAR and they were only gonna
ask Ozzy you know they weren't gonna
acknowledge the other guys so [ __ ] them
did those uh sexy model shots that you
took are those still on Google and
everything you remember when you had
Earl do a sexy fashion shoot whoo mmm
remember you were naked you got your
feet up in the air yeah yeah I mean I
could just I could see the photo
they were good it was a good photo I I
had so much fun you were naked in a
photo
yeah cuz remember I took shots
of Lily then we flip this scenario where
they shot pictures of me I am so I'm now
like Earl I'm [ __ ] blanked out all
kinds of you look up Troy look up black
ro I mean they get ya black girl naked
try that come on
okay yeah that's this guy's a different
[ __ ] great yeah black girl runnin Fez
that's a hung in shape Earl they're
alien Sam while these are old pictures
yeah Sam you look like a baby Lily yeah
that's a good picture
Earl took that picture yeah he did but
then we had the exact same man you
remember that picture I remember her
picture yeah the exact same pose but it
was Earl but it looks like it's been
scrapped from the internet it shouldn't
be yeah he'll jerking off to it no I
didn't [ __ ] problem
did you ever have people coming up to
you and you're trying to manage the vibe
at the Hard Rock like is that we're
radio fans stuff that you had done all
the time and what would they say no they
were like you know you know love you on
the air say I did the guys you know why
are you making out a guy that we that's
he's I know I know I'm saying we get
sexually you know you see how into it
early look at his face I know the drill
but your shirts like your your old chest
is exposed in that photo by me I didn't
get a chance to talk to you about your
set that [ __ ] gervase that was so
goddamn funny
oh thanks Ryan so [ __ ] edgy Thank You
Man I can't believe how far that you're
taking that unsuspecting audience that
was killing me thank you really really
yeah you were great - I was a really
good night man I appreciate it he was
fun to hang out with that night right
who's great yeah yeah yeah just died was
just a story of us in the green room
chatting and eating snacks it was it was
a nice night yeah I saw him at
Caroline's like with that last weekend
right yeah there's over Thanksgiving and
there is a bit that I told you that I
liked that it's like it you you sit
there waiting to see if the audience is
gonna go on this ride you know I mean
and then when they do yeah it's like
they're you got them you never 100% of
them right right now some people like
what yeah there's a couple of vegetable
people
okay we have zero that's really nice why
is your face so much darker than your
body are you aware that your shoulders
are light looks like they superimpose my
no no that's you I recognize the feet
yeah I know those legs anyway I would
recognize those heels from across the
room I'm gonna tell you something wrong
thanks you are I would have expected a
little more definition in the leg you
know you're you're skinny you're in good
shape but just not not a ton of muscle
and the George face probably it probably
be a camera flash or a lighting issue it
looks like you yeah it looks like you
have Sammy Sosa torso now you look good
there any Sosa yeah we can't see your
glutes unfortunately because you're
known for those is that what you'd like
to see well I mean Earl is known me look
he's a great guy he's gonna phenomenal s
sad thing that you can't tell from here
as he was [ __ ] donkey tail on it do
you like this shot kept the bowtie you
get the [ __ ] hand the face she's
super sexy he got the tie he's gonna
marry the Kardashian oh yeah right oh
definitely husbands always turn out well
yeah them are automated what do you
think of everything that's gone on with
with Kanye West since he married Kim
Kardashian yeah I was a fan and now I'm
just like he needs to the nagas hat he
needs to go away
the man had you too much it wasn't even
that I think I think he's just sick in
the head I said he's legitimately sick
in the head a medical attention
yeah well he's not medication he's not
doing anything destructive him he's
still putting out music and shoes he
makes an ass out of himself sometimes on
Instagram but who cares like he's not
he's not doing anything the Turnham
right they're still working and he still
may stop with the president he literally
held court with the president he's the
only guy ever so shut Trump up do it it
was just sat there well Trump liked it
there was a famous black guy who likes
him right so he was like oh yeah right
press especially a young guy a young guy
like that a relevant guy yeah who loves
him great took over that Prisco yeah it
was uncomfortable he didn't say a lot of
important things no no well did you
think though he sit important things not
at all I mean he's just I'm watching I'm
cringing he missed a spot
too far the fact